from last summer's great heat wave to
the beast from the east finding out what
Mother Nature has in store for us is a
national preoccupation the weather
forecasters we rely on are themselves
relying on delicate satellite
instruments to find out what's going on
in the atmosphere but as 5g moves from a
plan to reality that crucial weather
data may no longer be reliable the new
5g frequencies will allow instant
connections to billions of devices but
meteorologists satellites also use some
of those frequencies to measure things
like water vapor rain snow atmospheric
temperature cloud and ice water vapor
for instance emits a natural signal of
23.8 gigahertz so satellites use that to
monitor weather systems but some of the
5g frequencies already sold off to
networks are very close to 20 3.8
gigahertz which could interfere with
critical weather data during cyclone
Fany in India a few days ago
satellites kept a constant eye on the
storm and helped authorities warn people
when to leave forecasters say without
data like that lives could be at risk
this is the new boy the noisy neighbor
coming onto the scene and that could
well be a conflict if you take away than
that part of the weather forecast if you
like it's going to be very very nature
and make life more difficult for weather
forecasts to be able to piece those
pieces together in terms of being able
to look down on the earth look to see
whether the storms are the Hurricanes
the typhoons and other things as well
this mast on a building here in East
London is just one of several sites in
the UK already trying out the new 5g
technology not so much a distant dream
as already a fact here on the ground and
in the US it's being rolled out in
cities like Chicago and Minneapolis and
frequencies close to that all-important
twenty three point eight gigahertz have
already been auctioned off
which is why forecasters are speaking
out we need to look at how the rest of
the international community will handle
these particular frequencies for 5g
because if we lose skill forecasting the
weather over and
America that will have downwind effects
in Europe we looked at superstorm sandy
here in the United States and without
some of these millimeter wave bands from
weather satellites sandy would have
actually gone toward Europe and as we
know with devastating consequences sandy
made landfall in the eastern coast the
United States and it turned out the
weather satellites with these millimeter
wave frequencies were very important in
informing that forecast three to four
days out as our weather gets more
extreme the issue gets evermore
important international regulators will
decide this October on which frequencies
can be used for 5g meteorologists are
hoping the winds of change will be
gentle ones nor shadek Sky News